fisticuffs it's an open area Fight Like
a Man Man fight each other one the
motorboat Joe but cheese in my face
chocolate face on whoa whoa whoa I'm
playing this game and it's amazing sorry
okay
holy [ __ ] yeah it's pretty amazing I
gotta say mine doesn't stop sliding I
wanted like say like rise to it wait
wait Christ say they say their catch me
cry god damn right - too much left me a
bad guy what just happened
Oh kill oh god wait let me reload nice
kick on that barrel I don't know I do I
wish I knew but I don't think anyone
knows see you yeah oh no you got to do
the tricks Ken this Thursday why not oh
that's nice I'll take that
nevermind then I guess
Oh like Renee damn hello
kill everyone Oh dive kill yes how do I
activate this emotion let's see it's
coming I don't know why I did it here
god damn it everyone is dead I don't
have enough space in my freaking dive
killer [ __ ] I'll admit that was good
it was good
you're welcome that's what you get
backflips all the way oh my God all the
backflips
so many bad house yeah how do you first
person must be amazing yes see not sure
reality this game and no first world
problems double slide [ __ ] Hey
Oh know what I don't understand what you
get points for I really don't but I'm
killing everyone in the coolest way in
like I don't love it I don't understand
why I don't get all the point oh god I'd
open to their name oh hey got you anyway
oh that's let's do that oh hello how
convenient
okay damn it whoa whoa
kung-fu master skills I don't know a lot
of backflips that's what I'm think
damnit cry anyway can we get a replay
all night I don't know how do I get out
of this bathroom I can do amazing
backflips but I can't lie to this I
can't get out of this room Oh what
there's cocaine everywhere as they can
oh sorry just notice that I thought it
was snow wait no no are you telling me
it's not ice
that's quite childhood all right I'll
play the same good old character this
one doesn't have as many mushroom four
flips and [ __ ]
no know that I know this map this map is
from the original I believe it's just
changed a bit oh this is an old old map
old old old old
oh the old man yeah this one is smaller
this should be more intense oh god we
have rooftops yeah yeah that was Mike
hell Friday little grin I hate you
you're welcome
You cheeky bastard cheeky bastard cheeky
bastard thank me another Z Oh wrong
yeah oh I got someone by falling down
that's amazing ah worth it I can just
lay here this is amazing
does this count as a cake and Isle if
she's just laying down yeah you can lick
you the devas many times if you like
right how do I not kill with a H good
thank you thank them don't come here
don't come here don't come here I have
all the money hey Dana
oh I have to deliberate oh [ __ ] Oh God
come up here come up here waiter
alligator god dammit god dammit what is
happening yo I'm gonna shoot ya amazing
the hell are you doing at that Ken I
don't know what are you watch is it
working out for you hey minx
oh my god damn it the building's I gotta
kill for that for some reason huh
whatever
oh my god I'm sliding like a banana oh
my god this is a man ghetto I'm at it
right now oh oh oh oh
help help help oh boy I was amazing oh
my god this is ridiculous
Jesus all right amazing oh yeah there
they go
that's amazing to be that guy now II
know it ain't no crime oh [ __ ] is
shooting me it's not me
I punch me come on punch me case fight
me out ha ha ha
oh you want to do that oh [ __ ] yeah
there you go let's go jump up and punch
each other and see you wins amazing Oh
God
oh [ __ ] I actually made it holy [ __ ]
this map is amazing I love this map
ah
Oh what's it out the target bit the dust
yeah I was fooling when I became the
target ah you really put the dust there
what happened you just did I'd use
literally just drops on your device ah
that's [ __ ]
damn it well oh I'm the main amazed how
the hell am i running and the target at
the same time what the hell is happening
hey don't shoot a man while a front
flips Oh God
it's Oh God I'm alive come on get up get
up get up get up I'm not dead I'm not
dead help that one please for the love
of God help me okay I can still do it
can still do it okay let's see here not
dead yet oh now it's confirmed
every dive into each others they'll come
weird thing ever stop hands we get their
spin in the air you know together
holding hands okay I'm sorry I never it
was pretty amazing
no God I'm not dead yet I'm not dead yet
yes No
[Laughter]
oh yeah jump off at the same time sort
of thing but like it the same sort of
spot okay me and cry it together
I'm here this one here this will hear
away we should just walk I landed on top
of you you later for me thanks
[Applause]